what did you just say
that again
I found a one dollar bill yeah but how
did you find it um well and on the floor
how Mark how did you find it on the
floor on Walmart rolled up rolled up you
found a rolled up one dollar bill in
Walmart
on the floor
people do Coke out of a one dollar bill
what what kind of broke biodynamics does
you do Coke out of a one dollar he's
supposed to do Coke out of a hundred
dollars not that I've listened I've
never done it but I have some friends
who say they Don't Like Cocaine but they
like the smell of it
a one dollar bill help me I'm poor poor
good grief man whatever they're snorting
that's not cocaine if you need a one
dollar bill to do it